did you notice that there hadn't been
much interesting AI news in the last few
weeks and I know that's news to all the
accounts that Proclaim huge AI news
every 3 days but I mean actually and I
even had a whole video ready on that
hibernation going over a bunch of new
papers on some of the hurdles ahead as
we inch closer to AGI but then a couple
of announcements came tonight and that
video will have to wait the mini AI
winter which is more of a cold snap
really might be drawing to an end but
after covering those announcements we're
going to see evidence that no matter
what AI Tech Titans tell you never leave
your hypom at home first what just got
announced by Sam Alman and open AI well
it's 12 days of releases and that's all
they tell us but we can join the dots
and piece together some reporting to
find out a bit more about what's coming
what's almost certainly coming in these
next 12 days is Sora at long last in
case you've long since forgotten what
Sora is it's a text to video generator
from open aai it was first showcased
back in February of this year and even
though it's been almost a full year I
would argue that some of these demo
videos are still the best I've seen from
a text video model a version of Sor was
leaked by disgruntled artists around a
week ago and that's how some people were
able ble to generate these clips some of
these are obviously state-of-the-art but
then some of them are less impressive
and what we learn unofficially is that
it seems like there might be a SORA
turbo mode in short a model that
generates outputs more quickly but with
less quality I'll have more on
hallucinations in a minute but what else
might be coming in these 12 days well
very likely their smartist model which
is called 01 one of their employees
writing under an alias said first open I
is unbelievably back that's yesterday
someone asked give us full 01 and he
said okay indeed open AI senior vice
president of research newly promoted
Mark Chen wrote If you know you know the
full version of 01 simply called 01 as
compared to 01 preview looks set to be
the smartest model at least in terms of
mathematics and coding that doesn't
automatically mean it will become your
chosen model in some areas it actually
slightly underperforms the currently
available 01 preview that does though
leave one question for me which is what
are they going to do to fill the other
10 days according to one of their key
researchers they're going to have to
ship faster than the goalpost move and
now that chat GPT has surpassed 300
million weekly active users just 3
months after it surpassed 200 million
weekly active users no one can deny that
plenty of people might use anything they
do ship of course none of us have to
wait for things like Sora there are some
Epic free tools that you can use today
that I will show you at the end of this
video but the biggest news of the day
didn't actually come from open aai it
came from Google Deep Mind with their
presentation on Genie 2 in short it's a
model that you can't yet use but which
can turn any image into a playable world
and there's something just a little bit
ironic about the announcement of Genie 2
tonight the background is that I covered
Genie 1 on this channel and talked about
it potential moving forward the playable
worlds that Genie one could conjure up
were decent but pretty low definition
and limited but I noted from the paper
that the architecture could scale
gracefully with additional computational
resources that's not the irony the irony
is that just a couple of days ago I
interviewed the person who managed and
coordinated this genie2 project Tim
rocktashel this was for a podcast that's
been released on my AI insiders platform
on patreon I will of course go through
the genie2 announcement the demo videos
and what they say is coming next but I
can't help but point out I directly
asked Tim Rock dashel about Genie 2 the
paper it capped out I think 2.7 billion
parameters I I just wonder you might not
be able to say but surely Genie 2 you
know 270 billion parameters or something
is that something that you're working on
or excited about as with more data cuz
the paper even talked about how one day
we might train on a greater scale of
internet data all of YouTube potentially
is that something you're working on or
could speak about at all I'm excited
about this uh you can just look
basically what happened over the last
few months since Genie was published
there's for example The Oasis work that
came out a few weeks ago so where people
basically learned a new network to
simulate Minecraft before that there was
a paper learning to simulate Doom right
using new network that space is
definitely heating up and I think it's
exciting I think maybe at some point
these simulators these learn simulators
are getting fast and Rich enough so that
you then can also use them to adversar
probe abodi AGI and and like teacher new
capabilities the reason I was
interviewing him by the way is because
he is the author of the brand new book
AI 10 things you should know but what
really is Genie 2 and what does it say
about what's coming Deep Mind call it a
foundation World model and essentially
you give it a single image and Genie 2
will turn it into an interactive world
the world might not quite be as high
resolution as the original image but you
can use keyboard actions to control that
world jump fly skip swim all that kind
of thing I can imagine this being used
for dream sequences within games where a
character might have a dream of an
alternate reality and you can interact
with that world or maybe in the future
websites instead of having static images
in the background or even looping videos
will have interactive environments that
you can play like games but just a few
quick caveats these worlds these
Generations on average last 10 to 20
seconds or for up to a minute next is
even though they seem that way these
example videos aren't quite real time as
it stands if you want real time
interaction you'd have to suffer from a
reduction in quality and let's be honest
these outputs weren't exactly high
resolution to begin with so we're not
talking about replacing AAA games
anytime soon next the outputs can go
quite wrong quite quickly with no real
explanation like in this one a ghost
appears for no reason in this one the
guy started with a snowboard but then
immediately decides just to run the
course as Google wrote the character
prefers parkour over snowboarding yes by
the way the initial prompt could be a
real world image and that of course is
super cool it can kind of model lighting
although we're not talking Ray tracing
here and it can it says model gravity
but look at this horse jump on the left
I wouldn't say that's terribly high
accuracy physics this bit though I did
find more impressive which is that Genie
2 is capable of remembering parts of the
world that are no longer in View and
then rendering them accurately when they
become observable again so if you look
at the characters they'll look away from
something look back to it and it's
mostly the same as when they first
looked away interestingly in the
announcement page which didn't yet come
with a paper they actually pushed a
different angle for why this was
important they said that if we're going
to train General embodied agents in
other words AI controlling a robot
that's bottleneck by the availability of
sufficiently rich and diverse training
environments and they gave an example of
how they use Genie 2 to create this
interactive world and then told an AI
agent to for example open the red door
the SEMA agent which I've covered before
on the channel was indeed able to open
the red door but I personally would put
an asterisk here because it's an AI
agent trained on this AI generated not
particularly realistic world because of
the start Gap that exists between these
kind of simulations and our Rich complex
reality I'm not entirely convinced that
this approach will lead to Reliable
agents of course Google deepmind could
well prove me wrong they say that they
believe Genie 2 is the path to solving a
structural problem of training embodied
agents safely while achieving the
breadth and generality required to
progress towards AGI now of course my
objection would fall away if we had a
path for removing these creative but not
particularly reliable AI hallucinations
but as even the CEO of Nvidia recently
admitted we are quote several years away
from that happening his solution as you
might expect is just buy more gpus some
of you may say that reliability issues
and hallucinations they're just a minor
bug they're going to go soon what's the
problem with Jensen hang saying that the
solution is still just a few years away
well I think many people including AI
lab leaders massively underestimated the
hallucination issue as I covered on this
channel in June of 2023 samman said and
I quote we won't be talking about
hallucinations in 1 and 1/2 to 2 years 1
and a/ half years from then is like
today and we are talking about
hallucinations and even at the upper end
we're talking mid 2025 and I don't think
anyone would now vouch for the claim
echoed by Mustafa sullan that llm
hallucinations will be largely
eliminated by 2025 in short the very
thing that makes these models great at
generating creative interpolations of
their data creative worlds is the very
thing that makes them unreliable when it
comes to things like physics remember
that even Frontier generative models
like Sora when given 10 minutes to
produce an output still produce things
where the physics don't make sense and
this links to a recent paper that I was
going to analyze for this video in
mathematics and plausibly physics large
language models based on the Transformer
architecture don't learn robust
algorithms they rely on a bag of
humanistics or rules of Thumb in other
words they don't learn a single cohesive
World model they deploy a collection of
simpler rules and patterns that's why
for example with Genie 2 and Sora you
get plausible continuations that if you
look closely don't make too much sense
imagine Sora or Genie 2 generating a car
going off a cliff and all the resulting
physics you might have hoped that their
training data had inculcated Isaac
Newton's laws of physics and you get a
very exact result but they don't
actually have the computational
bandwidth to perform those kind of
calculations instead it's a bit more
like this when models are tasked with
226 takeway 68 they get this vibe that
kind of feels like an answer between 150
and 180 that's one of the humanistics or
rules of thumb that these authors
studied patch together enough of these
Vibes or humanistics and you start
getting pretty accurate answers most of
the time each fistic they learn only
slightly boosts the correct answer logic
but combine they cause the model to
produce the correct answer with high
probability not reliability indeed their
results suggest that improving lm's
mathematical abilities may require
fundamental changes to training and
architectures and I totally get it this
is the same video that I showed you the
01 model getting 83% in an exceptionally
hard math competition but you may have
noticed that none of these models tend
to get 100% in anything for example
surely if they can solve 90 3% of PhD
level physics problems why do they only
get 81% in AP Physics that's the same 01
model that we're set to get in the next
12 days I almost can't help myself I'm
starting to cover the two papers that I
said I would cover another day but still
I just want to touch on this other paper
the ridiculously compressed tldr is that
they show that models do learn
procedures rather than memorizing
individual answers the way they show
this is really complex and does rely on
some approximation
estimating for example if you remove
these 500 tokens how would that affect
the model parameters and therefore the
likelihood of getting an answer right
you can then in short judge which kind
of sources the model is relying on for
particular types of question again what
the authors are showing is that the
models aren't memorizing particular
answers to reasoning questions like when
asked what is 7 - 4 in Brackets * 7
they're not looking up a source that
says the answer of 21 they're relying on
multiple sources that give the kind of
prec procedures you'd need to answer
that question but while that seems
really promising for these models
developing World models and true
reasoning they add this crucial caveat
they don't find evidence for models
generalizing from pre-training data
about one type of reasoning to another
similar type of reasoning you could kind
of think of that like a model getting
fairly good at simulating the physics of
the moon but not then applying that when
asked to simulate the physics of Mars in
distribution generalized ation versus
outof distribution generalization anyway
I've definitely gone on too long time to
bring us back to the real world and
before I end with that cute turtle and
how you can move it around here is
another real world tool that you can use
today this is assembly ai's Universal 2
Speech the text model and you can see
its performance here as many of you know
I reached out to assembly Ai and they
are kindly sponsoring this video I use
their models to transcribe my projects
and you can see the comparison not just
with universal one but with other
competitive models one thing I've
learned in doing so is don't always
focus on word error rate think about how
models perform with proper nouns and
Alpha numerics that is at least for me
what sets the universal family apart now
as we wrap up this video just for anyone
wondering about an update to simple
bench first what about the new Gemini
experimental models well they are rate
limited I might soon be getting early
access to something else but for now we
can't run it in full on some bench what
about deep seek R1 well again as of
today not available through the API what
though about alibaba's qwq model that
has been getting a lot of hype lately
but honestly what's new almost
everything gets hyped in AI of course I
am following all of the models coming
out of China and testing them as much as
I possibly can and I did read that
interview with the founder of deeps I
may cover that in a different video but
for now I could actually run qwq on
simple bench and unfortunately it got a
score below Claude 3.5 Hau so it doesn't
appear on the list I'm sorry that I
can't do a shocked faed thumbnail and
say that AGI has arrived but that's just
the result we got it was around 11% I'm
going to show you one more tool just
very quickly and you can use it for free
today it's clling 1.5 actually another
model coming out of China and you could
argue in a way it's a foretaste of the
kind of interactivity that something
like Genie 2 will bring again free to
sign up for at least five professional
generation ations click on the left to
upload an image I generated this one
with ideogram then go down to motion
brush then I selected Auto segmentation
so I could pick out the turtle and then
for tracking I drew this arrow to the
right then confirm of course go to
professional mode I only have two trial
uses left and then generate you control
the movement and you can end up with
super cute Generations like this so
whatever you found the most interesting
thank you for watching and have a
wonderful day